and what I want you to do it underneath
this heading is either you write the
numbers 1 to 25 you just what do you do
for fun is it all the way to 25 just
write them down on your page don't know
don't do anything multiple columns
because we're gonna be doing some things
on the right-hand side here that you
wouldn't have some space for okay so
just want to write them all the way now
now I'm convinced these numbers you are
very familiar with these are simple
objects because they're small numbers
you could probably written each of one
of these numbers hundreds maybe
thousands of times throughout your
lifetime already you're familiar with
these numbers okay
but I'd like to convince you there's
something deep going on here maybe
you've never noticed before
like the fish I want you to stare it out
which is a look again okay factors what
I'm interested in today right
factorizing is something you learn to be
very very early on maybe all the way up
to you seven okay so here's how I'd like
you to begin I would like you to write
out all of the factors of all the
businesses write all the factors up all
these notice it starts off pretty easy
right one it's only factors one no big
deal - what are its factors one two
three one three four what are the
factors are four one and two or okay I'm
listing them out right you don't have to
list them in ascending order as you go
to these other ones might start to get a
bit harder but you can't list them out
right I'll let me list all the factors
you might make this a bit of a
pedestrian task to do all I would play
what you do is to look again write the
factors down and tell me if there's
anything in interest do you think you
see that picture interest okay off you
go you're done who feels like they've
noticed something anything yeah
something I will enjoy something to
start with all right thank you now can I
just say right you never never ever take
something for granted right and
sometimes the most obvious things will
you lost inside I determining great one
is a factor of everything right fair
enough
thank you for noticing that someone gave
me something else yes
every wait say that again it's like
after what I think you said every other
number has 2 as a factor but I don't
think that's what you meant
because for example 3 does they'll have
two as a factor every so every alternate
number that's how much you mean okay so
and that's why right ok good to every
alternate number has a factor of 2 and
that's why we give them a name right
would call them that even numbers okay
he's a character is a path market notes
Dylan yeah yeah good so again by the way
the the the the characteristic of
oddness or evenness is something that we
have applied because it's a structure we
can see right it's a structure we can
see so we apply that link we can example
of this for every even number if you
double the second last factor so tell
looking yup and here for instance so
you're talking at the second biggest
factor so the second biggest factor is
always half of the actual number itself
is that right what do you guys think why
would that be why would that be there
for example after I hit 9 for instance I
can't possibly have a bigger factor than
that yeah
very good very good sir - apart from one
which doesn't really do anything
- is the smallest uh but you can divide
anything by weight we're just talking
about integers right so therefore
because you can't divide by anything
smaller than that the other factor can
never be bigger than this guy
right good inside okay someone give you
something else okay we why don't you
think about it for a little bit because
do you notice but by the way
articulating something is often the
hardest part of you find something you
like but how do I do I have the language
to do this right and it's okay
give us something a baby as a class we
can work something out right do you want
to think about a bit longer or try and
chuck an idea it's I J okay yeah yeah
look we've got here's an even number two
and then three and then four five six
seven yeah yeah it's doubling every time
is it okay so again we're getting and
there's something deep and sort of what
should I say almost harmonic about
what's going on it's like music that
there's this regular kind of beat to
this thing okay
someone give me something else did
anyone do anything with like did you
notice some numbers have more factors
than others did you notice that now
we've already noticed apart from one
what's the minimum number of factors you
have the middle number is to write the
the smallest number of factors you can
have is to write which numbers have two
factors prime numbers right now by the
way that is how we defined them right
you can see in this list one is clearly
special on his own right he's his own
man but everything else it's like okay
you got two factors that's two you got
two factors here and two thousands here
in fact you might like to because these
guys are very important you might like
to do as I'm doing
highlight these numbers which have just
two factors you might like to highlight
the products how many Prime's do I
haven't list for six hey all right
I've noticed that epidote another factor
just is to exclude one because he seems
to be a special case
have you noticed anything else do I need
to ask you to look again has anyone
noticed anything else about oh yeah
sorry
kind of weird isn't it let's have a look
at these up what we up you're afraid to
write is the gaps between the primes and
gaps between them right so this gap here
you're talking about how many numbers
are there in between so there's a gap of
1 p.m. right there's another gap of 1
here there's a gap of 3 from here to
here there's a gap of 3 I've got the one
gap of 3 well with the next prime being
24 25 26 27 only 29 weren't it how many
is that to the next prime 5 numbers in
between right ok what are you going to
set the gaps between the crimes one of
the gaps between the crimes are odd that
they need to change don't they and by
the way just a bit of a spoiler as you
go further the gap see crease in size
and as far as we can tell me did I can
do the ends of this but as far as we can
tell this gap will increase forever the
further you go
but the gaps are all on why are the gaps
all odd why can't there ever be two
numbers in between two different primes
okay all right
did you catch that by the way simple
thing but just by looking let me try to
explain this may be another way um when
we said there's a gap of one gap of wide
gap of three okay another way of saying
that is to go from this number to in
snakes prime I have two and two did you
remember that like it's a gap of one
number means it's plus two to get to the
next one and then plus two and then plus
4 and then prostitute etc okay now if
for instance we thought maybe the gap
was an even number that would be you'd
have to add an odd number right now I
don't care what numbers you begin with
if you start with a number X you add an
odd number and you get done for Y one of
these numbers has to be even right at
least one of them for example if you
start with three and you add an odd
number you get six so this one's even if
you start at two you'll end up at five
but that means this one's even right so
the gaps always have to be like this
otherwise you'll land on an even number
okay excellent starting get some what do
you see it's like they just so simple
but if you did you find it I still have
a couple up my sleeve no one else
noticed anything else
they push on this idea that we mentioned
before numbers right if they have only
two factors that's a smallest number of
factors you can have apart from one they
all have two factors right how many
factors do the rest of the numbers have
and are there any patterns there for
instance how many factors here three
three factors in fact it's you how many
factors how many you keep going keep
going tell me if you notice something
with you well I'd like you to it
finishes pattern you finish this pattern
and see if you can notice something